Tia Mowry showing off her new haircut
we're here the actress reveals a shorter
do with five new picks on the gram
embracing her new era I'm loving it in
the caption she writes there's something
so Bittersweet about a nice chop it
feels like a release of old memories
both good and bad but also an exciting
start to a new era Tia adds there's
nothing more Monumental to Market with
than a fresh cut just be you and this
new era T is talking about comes just
one month after a big life shift her
divorce from husband Corey harbrickt
finalized after 14 years of marriage I
am really I have to be honest with you
so overwhelmed by all of the support and
the love that I have received and I'm
just so grateful of the community and
just the fans that I have and the women
the DMS that I have gotten from so many
women that are going through the same
thing and just saying how they admire my
courage and my strength it I mean it has
just been
I feel so blessed feeling blessed and
living her best life
yeah on Tuesday Tia swung by the
Spider-Man across the spider-verse
premiere with her son Cree I I love the
family affair of it all tonight I mean
if I'm being very honest with you we had
gone to the Little Mermaid Premiere
without him and he was like so jealous
so I was like okay fine we'll come here
and this is like his favorite right he
loves this character what are you most
looking forward to about tonight I
personally just spending quality time
with my son just to get that time in
um it means a lot to me and this is
definitely one of his favorite you know
uh characters out of the whole Marvel
you know Heroes and so I'm like anything
for you right yeah
cool mom
points or award hopefully I get some
points for tonight too right yeah I mean
you already have so
[Laughter]
[Music]